ce l'avete presente quel birbantello che
ogni tanto appare nei miei video ecco
l'altro giorno non so se avete visto il
mio instagram stories che era pieno di
queste cose allora che è un video
iacopino ecco nel caso non si fosse
capito e roero appunto con lui abbiamo
registrato una prova non ridere
challenge ce l'ho fatta con lui la prova
non ridere challenger a prevedere come
sarebbe uscito un esperimento mettiamola
così vi lascio al video ragazzi buona
visione
e allora adesso adesso facciamo questa
cosa serivi hai perso non devi vivere
guardiamo lo stesso video e non devi
ridere ci sei suoi riti hai perso mai
partiamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
va male perché guardate se si spostano
solo
ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]
a me fa ridere muri di carini pa ridere
se ti guardi queste ore sul sito 9
prodotti più bravo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no
gli ho resistito ho resistito
e stato bravo ha messo tali delitti
sarà bellissimo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sembravo e ti stai tenendo
questo l'appello a sinistra cos'è cos'è
la chimica assurda questo è l'appello
dai ha perso a rischio sono stato bravo
ma perché siamo quali è chiusa era un
respiro doveva farlo insieme al 3 1 2 e
adesso secondo questa la sfida di una
sfida preferì eroi ci sei
[Musica]
[Applauso]
perché ricca atletico no che sì mi può
che schifo cosa appena visto bruttissimo
[Applauso]
[Risate]
ti ho sentito anche ad essi va beh dai 1
poi non è vero non è vero
cosa abbiamo visto che sei perso bisogna
fare di più la tua
[Musica]
no ovviamente lo rais ucciso
non ci posso non è possibile non è
possibile un genio beh questo figlio chi
ha vinto io come io hai vissuto
religiosa rito ha vinto io ma come
l'altro vinto io ho vinto io non vado
perchè lì ho resistito
ho resistito ammanchi sì è vero che è
facile grazie a tappeto su gatto
potrebbe sul gatto con brothers
[Applauso]
[Musica]
non è vero bellissimo che sarà
bellissimo sarà bellissimo
cos'è sta storia è un po che non aiuta
[Applauso]
bruttissimo questo era bruttissimo no
non ci credo
questo che la aspetta questo voglio dire
no va bene una parola lentamente mi fa
male no veramente la perdita una papera
così come fotogrammi tempo bellissimo
[Musica]
disamina questo un fortino un altro se
più bello è che se non soprattutto
intelligenza
sii sincero sincero chi ha vinto ma non
è vero una stretta nelle sincero vinto
lino facciamo così decide chi ha vinto
carta forbice sasso
forbice e non fare quello che facciamo
noi facciamo adesso la facciamo carta
pollice sasso
direi a suoli video si conclude qua
ovviamente ho vinto io perché c'è ci
facciamo con la prossima volta però il
no perché so che guarderà questo video
quindi detto jacopo tanto ci prossima
volta ci facciamo e vinci tu forse forse
come ai ragazzi spero che questo video
vi sia piaciuto cose e ciò che è vissuto
un momento è un mi piace anche a facili
facebook come mi domando schizzare se si
discute di ci vediamo il prossimo video
ragazzi
[Musica]